DANIEL: Question from Andrew
about commas in prices.
I think it was a dot, but
if it wasn't, that's
just a typo on me.
So, not 100% there, but I'm
pretty sure it was a dot.
But yes, prices need to have
periods and not commas.
Please file bugs on all
these open source
libraries that I showed.
If, for some reason there's a
feature that isn't out there,
as I'm documenting these, if
you go to the Python client
library, you can click view
source and then within there,
there are subtabs.
There's a changes subtab.
I've made probably 10 commits in
the last five days, because
as I'm documenting it, I'm
finding things I'd like to
document aren't necessarily
there.
So as we make this big
documentation push, a lot of
these missing features
are going to show up.
LUKE: [INAUDIBLE].
Yes, OK, so Luke says dry run
is not where you expect it.
It's under Product.
It's not under Product Entry.
The reason dry run and warnings
in .NET are under the
product query class is because
that's really where the
query's being built, right?
And the product entry class is
for the body of the request
whereas the URI is something
distinct from the body, right?
So the query class takes a
product entry, but the query
itself needs to build the
entry in some way.
I'm not a C# guy, but the
guys who designed it--
that was their closest
equivalent of using a keyword
parameter in Python or PHP.
Dynamic languages like Python
and PHP just really are not
the same animal, and so you do
have to make compromises, and
the APIs won't always
look the same.
But for the most part--
Andrew, your question
about 1 MB cap--
so you mean request size like
headers plus payload?
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE]
DANIEL: I take it you don't
have a microphone, Andrew?
So for those watching the
YouTube video, if you can't
see already, Andrew was asking
if the 1 MB cap on requests
applies to the request size,
or just the XML payload.
And I believe he's asking if
it's body, headers, and any
other information with the
request, or if it just replies
to the body.
So off the top my head, I
believe it's just body, but
I've never really
looked into it.
So I can ask, and I will post
to the forum and answer.
I'm going to type real quick.
Hopefully it's not too loud.
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE]
So the next question Andrew is
asking is, if he GSIPs the
request will that
change things?
No.
As with feeds, you can also send
zipped feeds, so we're
going to be able to detect
the way you zipped it.
And if the way we've detected
you zipped it doesn't actually
unzip, then we're just going
to reject the request. And
they'll be either a generic
error, or they'll be a
specific error.
I'm not sure off the top of my
head if there is a couldn't
unzip error.
But we'll just reject the
request and tell you, zip it
in a better fashion.
But for the most part, we're not
going to have any issues
unzipping it.
There are pretty great libraries
out there for doing
that, and internally we don't
have issues with it.
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE]
DANIEL: So the next question
Andrew is asking is, if I zip
it, and it ends up as 0.9
MB, but when it's
unzipped, it's 2 MB.
Will I still be under the cap?
Yes.
All we care about is what's
going over the wire.
When you're talking about the
quality of an API, one of the
issues you want--
all right, hold on one second.
Thanks, Jasmine, for
all your help.
She's got to go.
She's plus eight from me right
now, so it's late for her, but
it was great to have
your help here.
Have a great day.
Back to Andrew's question.
The quality of the API--
you're really worried about how
fast requests come in, and
how fast it takes to receive
them, right?
And then how fast you
can send a response.
The issue is the speed that it's
going to take for you to
send that 1 MB.
We don't care about anything
after that.
Once it gets there,
it gets there.
Processing 1 MB, processing
2 MB, it's not that hard.
It's a pretty small size.
However, sending it over
the wire is the
bottleneck there, right?
And so, we don't care if
it unzips to 2 MB.
Question from Luke.
I mentioned quota limits.
What's the limit?
By default--
I don't know the limit
off the top my head.
It's always changing.
We don't publish it for a
reason, because it's changing,
because it's subject to
change, et cetera.
But what I'll say is, if you
need more quota, and you're
not doing something malicious,
we'll give you more quota.
So if you run into it, then
just let me know.
Post it on the forum, or get in
touch some other way, and
we'll increase your quota.
But the quota is in such a way
that, unless you are one of
the biggest internet retailers
in the world, you probably
won't have to worry about it.
But like I said, there are
channels for you to get your
quota increased if there
is a use case for it.
So don't be worried
about that.
So any other questions?
LUKE: Daniel, can
you hear me OK?
DANIEL: I can.
I can.
LUKE: I just unmuted myself.
On the quota limit thing, the
reason I ask is that, if I'm
batching requests, but I'm doing
this in an automated
way, I might be firing out
100 a minute to you.
DANIEL: Gotcha.
So that's a good point.
I'm sorry that I glazed
over on that.
There are two different
types of quotas.
There's a daily quota, and
that's really just what I was
talking about, but there's
also a QPS quota, right?
You guys know what
denial of service
attacks look like, right?
And so, to protect against that,
any service is going to
have some sort of QPS limit.
And so, like Luke said, if you
do send up 100 batch requests
in a minute, you may
get dinged for QPS.
So a few things you can do.
One is-- and I don't
recommend this--
but if you don't have any cap,
or any sort of guard against
how quickly you're
sending requests
relative to each other.
Like, four in the same second.
If your system allows it, then
you should have an error catch
where you're going to see the
error corresponding to--
it's something like "internal
reason, exceeded quota".
It's on the error code list
in the documentation.
But, have some catch, and then
just do exponential back off.
So you sleep a second, make
the request again.
OK, it didn't succeed,
double the time.
OK, so then we go up to two
seconds, and just do an
exponential back off, and
obviously exponential growth
is pretty fast. So you
don't want to back
off infinitely, right?
You don't want to back
off until 2 to the
100th second, right?
Have some safeguard in there,
but up to a certain threshold,
that's really your best bet.
But I would say, have some
sort of throttling.
If you're running more than one
process, have some sort of
shared queue, or a set of shared
queues where you can
see how quickly you're
doing that.
Thanks for the point, Luke.
There are QPS limits, and you
will hit them if you have a
lot of updates all at once, or
if you're doing one of these
bi-monthly or semi-monthly
cleans, and you're sending a
lot of requests at
a small part.
LUKE: I have a couple
more questions--
DANIEL: Like Andrew
says, exponential
back off is your friend.
Sorry to interrupt.
LUKE: I have a few
more questions.
Should I ask them
all in a row?
DANIEL: If other people don't
have questions, I
don't have an issue.
If people have an issue,
let's take turns.
So it sounds like
it's all you.
LUKE: Right, good.
OK, so MCA.
We just had the joy of that.
Actually, I have another
quick one.
You said they're human
over there, right?
DANIEL: Yes.
LUKE: I requested
the MCA account.
They declined it.
They don't give you a reason.
Then after you got it passed
for me, I requested they
reestablish API whitelisting,
they declined that, too,
without a reason.
DANIEL: That's a process
that's still being
straightened out.
The number of API users is
much higher than the
number of MCA users.
I chatted with the ops folks
about that, and it was really
just a miscommunication
in process.
You're sort helping us dog
through the process in some
ways, right?
For the most part, if all else
fails, I'm your support
channel, or my peers within
the commerce team.
That shouldn't have happened.
I'm sorry it happened.
It's a process that's a little
less clean than the overall
API process.
LUKE: Well, at least they
declined me quickly.
They didn't make me wait a
week and then decline me.
On the MCA, it looks like the
verify claim of the sub
account URLs is a
manual process.
Is that right?
DANIEL: Yes and no.
If you're literally verifying a
URL with Google for the very
first time, yes, it's
a manual process.
And it doesn't have
to be that manual.
A lot of times, they'll give you
some hex digest, and you
say, put a page at URL, slash,
this long link with a
particular token in it.
And that's sufficient
for verification.
So you can script a lot of
that process and take the
human part out of
a lot of that.
But for the most part, if
you're using an MCA as a
marketplace, then you're going
to want your clients with the
sub accounts to do
that anyway.
LUKE: OK, so you're saying if
they claim the URL in their
merchant-center account, and I
then consume it through the
API, then--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL: That's a special
use case.
We can talk offline about that
for non-standard fixes.
But for new accounts you're
creating, if you're using a
URL different than the URL
on the parent, then you
will need to verify.
If you are using the URL
on the parent, or some
sub-domain, or something like
that, from the parent, you
don't have to worry about it.
LUKE: These are private
URLs that they
have owned and purchased.
So yeah, they're going to
be different domains.
DANIEL: Yeah, that will need
to be a manual process.
But there are pretty sufficient
docs on the
Merchant Center for that.
So if that's something you
wanted to provide for your
clients, just say, hey,
go to this link.
If you have any issues,
let me know, or
escalate to this forum.
There's a lot of support
channels in place for that.
LUKE: OK.
And also, it doesn't look like
we can set the business
information and the customer
service information on the sub
account through the Manage.
DANIEL: Yeah, all attributes
are those documented on the
documentation.
Hold off on your questions
for a second, Luke.
John Strakjs, J-S, I believe--
I don't know if I pronounced
that right--
has a few questions.
So we're going to let him ask
his questions for a sec.
JOHN STRAKJS: Hello, Daniel.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL: Strack or Strash, or--
JOHN STRAKJS: It's Strack-en.
DANIEL: But your email-- how
do you say Strak J-S?
JOHN STRAKJS: Oh, how
do I say Strak J-S?
DANIEL: That's how you say it.
All right--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL: Cool.
All right, anyhow--
JOHN STRAKJS: Yeah, so I've just
got a couple of questions
about MCAs.
We've been using them for some
time, and we have a Java
program, which works fine.
First question is--
there's quite a lot
of attributes--
when you go onto the merchant
manually, there are lots of
fields to put in.
Via the MCA, those fields
are not there.
And I wonder whether, at some
point, the MCA API is going to
be changed to take in those
extra attributes.
DANIEL: A few things.
I wish I would have mentioned
this in the slides.
We do have--
I'll post a link to it here.
Sorry for my loud typing.
We do have an issues--
it's an empty Google code
hosting project just with
issues, for you to
vote up issues.
Man, I can't find it.
Hold on a second.
Sorry.
So you can go there and vote for
features like that or just
post them on the forum.
Say, we want them.
But that's a feature that
we've discussed.
Not necessarily everything
that you can set on the
merchant center.
But things like tax, account
level tax or
account level shipping.
Things like that we've discussed
and probably will be
adding, but I haven't
seen a design doc or
anything like that.
So we're not at that point yet,
but it certainly things
we're open to.
JOHN STRAKJS: Excellent, OK.
What I'll do is, I'll look on
there, and I'll put some
suggestions in.
DANIEL: OK, great.
Yeah, so everyone, if you
want to look in chat--
if you go to code.google.com/
p/shopping-API-issues, you can
actually vote up issues or
create new issues, and I will
relay them to the teams who
are actually building this
stuff and adding features, and
doing things like that.
JOHN STRAKJS: I think you're
trying to actually connect to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], because we've
got several hundred
shops, which we kind of manage
under our accounts.
And it's trying to connect to
our account, with maybe--
DANIEL: So you're saying they're
not managed by the
MCA, but you'd like to inherit
them programmatically.
JOHN STRAKJS: Inherit
is a good word.
Yes, a shop may not be
registered as a merchant, but
we will actually set them
up via our API.
DANIEL: So I guess I'm
a little confused
at what you're asking.
So their account is managed
by the MCA account?
JOHN STRAKJS: That's correct.
Exactly right.
DANIEL: And what is it that
you'd like to do?
You'd just like to set
account-level settings for
them, is what you're saying?
JOHN STRAKJS: Yes.
I'll give you an example.
Say someone actually has a real
shop, with a real location.
Now, it'd be fantastic
to be able to--
but they haven't got a Google
Merchant Account.
So we're managing their
products for them.
What we'd really like to do is
to upload them, and connecting
up with their address.
So that if they're using--
DANIEL: Oh, like local.
JOHN STRAKJS: Exactly
right, yes.
DANIEL: OK, we just launched
support for local products.
It's a little bit of a
fragmented process.
They need to sign up for a
Google Places account.
Let me try to find
a link for this.
You can keep talking, and I'll
try to talk while I'm
googling for it.
But, they need to sign up for
a Google Places account, and
then they can actually
link that.
But it's not exactly easy
to do with the API yet.
But it's something we're
looking into.
We are launching a new
feed to manage local
product data, though.
But there's still, like I said,
a bit of fragmentation.
Let me find it--
nearby stores, create
an account with
Google Local shopping.
So here is a relevant link.
I didn't read it, but I read the
headline, so I think it's
the right one.
Yes.
So there is a track of related
Merchant Center posts about
it, but there's no great way
through the API to just
specify it.
But it's something that we're
really hoping to make less
fragmented.
But I think that may require
something like a Google Places
API, which doesn't really exist
in the capacity that
you'd like it to.
JOHN STRAKJS: Right.
Thanks so much for answering
that question.
My second question, I think,
is tied into our account in
that we can update our MCA
accounts, but we can't create
any new ones.
We seem to have hit a limit.
We have a manual workaround
at the moment.
Presumably one day, that'll be
resolved, and we'll be able to
create more accounts.
DANIEL: So the MCA quota is
not the same as your items
quota, or account level
items quota.
And even that stuff
can be a pain
sometimes, as Andrew knows.
But MCA quota, they actually
look at your account before
they approve more quota.
And then they say, if you have
a bunch of accounts that
aren't being used, then
please delete them,
or things like that.
If you want to email
me offline, we
can deal with this.
I don't know what your current
account limit is, but for
marketplace has sort of backed
off on the original quota.
And supplemented it
a little bit.
Though, like I said, it's
really case by case.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN STRAKJS: I suspect we've
got a couple of sub accounts
which are empty.
Maybe what we need to do is go
around and have a little tidy
up and delete those.
Which might then
help the quota.
DANIEL: Right.
Yeah, if you're getting to that
point, and you have a
bunch of accounts that are full
of data, then, obviously,
it's pretty clear cut.
You just need more accounts.
But if you're using it as a test
account, and you leave
some of the accounts you created
while testing just
around, then it's a little
more involved decision.
JOHN STRAKJS: Excellent.
Thanks so much for answering
those questions.
DANIEL: Luke, do you have some
more ques-- oh, looks like
Andrew has a question.
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE].
DANIEL: Andrew's question is,
you said we should keep track
of the unique URL for managing
each product.
In my software, I've been
generating these URLs using
the product ID and other
relevant data when I need
them, rather than
storing them.
Are there any plans to change
these URLs in the near future?
DANIEL: No.
That would be a huge
breaking change.
When I said keep track,
that was more like a
generalization, and you've
captured that generalization
perfectly, right?
You already have the data needed
to construct the URL.
It's four things.
It's the channel, online or
local, the language, the
product ID, and the
country, right?
So that's already embedded
within the product.
So if you're keeping your
product data local, you're
good to go.
No, we don't intend on making
such a huge breaking change.
Thanks for the question.
Yeah, smiley face
out of Andrew.
All right, Luke do you
have a question?
LUKE: Yeah, I think
I have one more.
I noticed something.
I didn't read up on it, but
the data quality service--
what can you say about that?
DANIEL: It's brand new.
We will be posting about it
soon, but nothing to say about
it right now.
Yeah, brand new.
It's been up for like,
four days.
LUKE: I was going to say, are
your own people using that to
judge our data quality, so that
if we use it, then we--
DANIEL: No, it's intended for
merchants and developers, not
for internal use.
LUKE: OK, so yours might
be stricter.
DANIEL: Yeah, the data quality
folks are in a completely
different part of Google.
So I don't actually interact
with them a whole lot other
than, like, when I have
upset developers.
LUKE: I was just wondering if
I used it, if I could avoid
running into any problems.
DANIEL: You probably could.
But like I said, we're going
to launch it formally soon,
and I'm going to hold off on
talking about until then.
LUKE: OK, I think that's
it for my questions.
I think I'm good.
DANIEL: Cool.
So this was great.
I think everyone has their
current questions resolved.
But as we all know, we probably
have bugs in our code
that we don't know about.
So we'll find out some more
questions as we go.
Thanks, everyone.
This was great, and I look
forward to doing another one,
probably in two weeks.
But you're all in a G+ circle
that I have, so I'll just post
to that circle.
I'll post to the forum,
may send an email.
I'll probably stop sending
emails, because it's a pain to
bcc a list of 40 plus people.
But anyhow, thanks everyone.
Have a great day.
And it was a pleasure
talking to you.